way back in 2003 the final matrix film
the matrix revolutions hit the big
screen it's hardly regarded as the
strongest installment in the famed
trilogy and by the time it left theaters
the matrix craze had significantly died
down with the 2020s continuing the trend
of endless reboots and sequels
excitement is back in the air for the
matrix resurrections which will debut
december 2021 and presumably pick up
where revolutions left off there's no
better time to begin refreshing your
memory on everything the matrix
franchise has to offer beginning with
the 1999 film that captivated a
generation from deep allegories that
carry more meaning today to innovative
filmmaking techniques that changed
cinema forever the matrix was by all
accounts a game changer it presented
audiences with philosophical quandaries
in an easy to understand way packed a
punch through its unique action
sequences and told a story that was more
than worth the price of admission plus
it added some incredible characters to
the pop culture pantheon if you're
killed in the matrix
you die here the body cannot live
without the mind
there's no denying keanu reeves neo is
the poster child of the matrix but one
would be remiss not to give carrie and
moss's trinity the spotlight she
deserves she played a big hand in the
first film story cementing her legacy
through one particular scene that still
has fans pausing rewinding and watching
again as we enter the matrix universe
for the first time it's made clear that
something isn't quite right a green
tinted dystopia looks like a normal city
but we feel in our bones that the whole
setup is different from the world that
we know we move to the interior of a
building swarmed by cops eventually
meeting trinity sitting at a computer i
think we can handle one little girl
despite being busted presumably for a
serious crime she refuses to go quietly
and delivers arguably the coolest
looking kick in the history of motion
pictures trinity hovering before a
dumbfounded police officer has become
the defining image of the character even
for those who've never seen the matrix
the scene itself has been parodied to
death over the years most recently
getting an homage in 2021's space jam a
new legacy the reason it's so iconic is
because of its use of a bullet time
camera rig it's a setup that included
dozens of cameras all in operation at
the same time capturing a 360 degree
image that appears frozen combine that
with a green screen carry an moss on
cables and slow motion after effects and
you've got yourself an unforgettable
movie moment when viewers watched
trinity leap into the air for the first
time it was clear that the matrix wasn't
going to look or feel like any action
movie before it the 1999 film is a
showstopper from beginning to end but no
other scene captured that pause-worthy
wow factor like trinity's kick the
famous trinity kick is an excellent
example of how the matrix and its
sequels changed the way hollywood's
general audiences think about visual
effects it was as if the collective
zeitgeist took the red pill and had
their eyes opened to a new way of
filming action sequences the matrix took
the art of the fight scene to a new
level by bringing in one of the biggest
names in the game to choreograph various
sequences the matrix directors lana and
lily wachowski hired director yoon woo
ping to train the actors for six months
prior to filming according to unilad at
the time focusing on stunt choreography
for that long was unheard of for a
hollywood film but the matrix proved
that fight scenes could be more than
punching and kicking with the right
people on board you could create a
visually stunning scene that rivals any
car chase but the matrix did far more
than merely give us cooler set pieces
the sci-fi flake altered the way people
think about not just action in movies
but philosophy the film was able to
seamlessly blend the two without the
matrix we may not have had inception
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
and district 9 just to name a few and of
course we also wouldn't have the matrix
resurrections which drops in theaters
and on hbo max on december 22nd 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie scenes are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]